now as we've been reporting nicholas
threatens to bring even more destruction
to the gulf coast including louisiana
where many people are still reeling from
hurricane ida cbs morning's lead
national correspondent david begno was
recently in the state david good morning
hard to believe good morning that
they're facing another flooding threat
when that area is still underwater
flooded with water and mud from ida two
weeks ago we were there just last week
and we saw that hurricanes affect not
only the living but the dead too
high above barataria louisiana on
private property surrounded by flood
water and just beyond a pile of trash
was a coffin
that had floated away during hurricane
ida
it was found in the woods
the graveyard where it had floated from
was just 300 yards away and it was
underwater we spotted a name plate
esther morton
i googled the name found the obituary
and reached one of her daughters
who told us that mrs morton who was a
custodian at the local high school for
more than 30 years
had been buried here eight years ago
oh my lord
it's been a while
since 2013.
that was the last time troy harvey saw
his grandmother's casket when he helped
to carry it at her funeral
i don't know
how he's supposed to get the casket
back into its place
but i'm sure they're not comfortable
having it sitting on their front lawn
either
jesus
well so much
it is estimated that between 30 and 50
caskets were displaced due to hurricane
itis storm surge
that's according to ryan seidemann who
flew over portions of southeastern
louisiana looking for coffins that got
away
seideman is chairman of louisiana's
cemetery response task force why do
coffins pop up from the ground in
louisiana
these
concrete burial vaults that are put on
the ground directly on the ground or
partially in the ground they tend to be
buoyant air pockets in
flood waters and they want to float and
so if those waters come in and rock them
back and forth enough
they'll just come up and travel with the
flood waters it is about getting back in
the ground as soon as possible
if there's anybody that can help us with
this it would be gladly appreciated
troy harvey did not have to look far to
find that help
i hate to see my grandmother imposing on
y'all bro
that's that that's the way it goes down
here on the body bro that's it bro
mm-hmm it's all good it's all good
brother i mean as soon as the ground can
get dried out bro we can put it back in
i got a trailer man we'll take them and
put it to rest the water go down
seriously bro yeah we'll take care of it
thank you my brother
what i told you bro my feet man it's
family that's it these men remembered
each other because they grew up right
here together 40 minutes outside new
orleans
but they haven't seen each other for 30
years since troy moved to texas
kindness is what brought them back
together
and will guarantee that mrs morton rests
peacefully
again
baby
to rebury those caskets families could
rely on assistance from fema in
louisiana now and they did this right
after hurricane katrina in 2005 they
actually now mandate that you identify
caskets for events just like this and
fema by the way will provide about eight
thousand dollars to families to make
sure that those coffins are properly
reburied that's the thing about your
stories they are always so layered it
never occurred to me that a caskets come
out of the ground that way but then it
ends up on that man's lawn it turns out
the two people know each other and
you're there when they
it's it's too much
human kindness is a beautiful thing but
but i'm filled though that that this
will have a good resolution as good as
it can and not just neighborly kindness
though it feels deeper than that yeah it
does and it provides perspective i'm not
being dismissive of what has happened up
here with trees falling down or a little
bit of flooding but there's people in
louisiana that are going through it yeah
thank you amen thank you david thank you
very much